we also don't want to not kiss so we'll
kiss with our tongues
that's why we kissed up Kourtney
Kardashian and Travis Barker are all
about the PDA and you might have noticed
their
um
unique smooching technique I'm just like
living life well now the pooch founder
is explaining why they kiss tongue to
tongue not lip to lip and honestly
it makes sense I mean it's a beautiful
thing yeah the lovebirds have touched
tongues at the Grammys the Academy
Awards the Met Ball and on social media
and during the latest episode of Hulu's
the Kardashians Court admits it's all
about not ruining the glam
I don't want to get lipstick all over
him and I don't want to like ruin my
lipstick but we also
don't want to not kiss so we'll kiss
with our tongues
that's why we kiss them genius thank you
but the connection between court and
Travis is more than just physical the
Blink 182 drummer turned 47 on Monday
and his wifey shared some sexy snaps
alongside a heartfelt message quote I am
beyond grateful for the day you were
born happy birthday to the husband of my
dreams my soul mate adding quote you
have changed my life forever
and Trav well he slid into the comments
to reciprocate that Vibe writing my
soulmate I love you forever it's really
nothing to hide yeah we're a pretty wild
but but still cool and relatable family
and on the famous family's reality show
Court opens up about her man's positive
influence leading up to the Met Ball I
feel like Travis definitely has that
chill energy and just reminds me like
we're doing it to have fun we're not
doing it to stress we're not doing it uh
worry about what everyone thinks about
us we're just like
doing it to have an experience together
and like have fun
that's how we live our life
[Music]